we're here in Yellowstone National Park
to follow some gray wolves and observe
the deadly brilliance of the pack they
had learned to cooperate hunting their
prey with many acting as one pack this
mother grizzly knows how to protect its
cub and itself stand your ground don't
be intimidated don't let the gray wolves
run you down
grizzly mom stands up to the gray wolves
and eventually they lose interest
stand up hold your ground
wolves know that large prey can be
dangerous if they fight back what the
wolves want is to get their prey on the
run like for example this herd of elk
now the Wolves can pan out over the hurt
waiting for an old or sad car just
unlucky elk to make a wrong move the
alpha male leads the hunt
he bides his time directing his troops
and eventually one alex stumbles
the hungry wolves quickly surround the
faltering victim they swarm in for the
kill and then the meal wolves are a
vital part of a healthy Yellowstone
Ecosystem
they filter out sick and weak animals
and herds
and help scavengers survive by providing
leftovers from their hunts this coyote
however is not only a scavenger but also
a competitor who's been interfering with
the kills of the pack so once again the
wolves use cooperation to guard their
turf and drive out the intruder